[music]
Hey, good morning everybody. Uh, great
to be here in Paris and excited about
this conference. Uh, it's a great space
to be in. Uh, just to give a quick
introduction to myself, my name is
Philip Lord. Uh, I'm CEO of Bitcoin
Japan. It's a publicly listed company.
Obviously, it has a a name that
everybody knows, but actually we
primarily invest in latestage growth
companies. So invested in SpaceX, Figure
AI, looking to invest in um other
companies uh you know in the later stage
uh but excited about the physical AI
space hence I invested in figure uh and
uh looking to meet good companies here.
So let me introduce uh my other
panelists uh Tao and um was it uh sorry
Raz so maybe you can give a quick
introduction to yourselves. Yeah. So,
uh, hi everyone. Great to be here for
the first time. Actually, I'm Raz. I'm
one of the GPS in a fund called
Greenfield Partners. We're a $2.5
billion AUM fund based out of Tel Aviv
in New York mostly focused on uh deep
tech, cyber, and AI.
>> Good morning everybody. My name is Tal
and I'm with Next Gear Ventures and I'm
a smaller fund invest in preed and seed.
We are have a presence here in Paris and
in Tel Aiv as well. Uh we invest in
mostly physical AI uh deep tech type of
startups.
>> Cool. Might I just ask the audience
who's an investor? Have you put your
hand up? Who's uh who's looking to
invest? And who's an operator? A
business uh business person in the
space? Anybody investors? Okay, cool.
And uh building businesses in the space.
Cool. There you go. That's a good sign.
You know, we don't want too many
investors in the room. That leaves
opportunity for people like us. Um yeah
so like let's start with the question
you know have we had our chat GBT moment
uh on um robots yet?
um little bit maybe okay I think we are
we are experiencing a renaissance of the
robots
but it's not yet CH GPT for me okay JGPT
is like wow it works it dances so you
decide if it's JPT for you or not yet
>> um look I think uh I don't think there's
going to be a CHP moment for uh for
physical AI to be honest I think uh CHP
moment was mostly focused focus on
distribution and reach uh at the end of
the day for consumers. Um I think in
industrial automation for example we're
way past the GPT three maybe even four
but for consumer probably not even close
to 2.5. Um so I think I think there's
time for more the consumer and and it's
very different in a sense of what we're
seeing in the world of AI in my
perspective.
>> Cool. Maybe we can talk about the world
to invest in at the moment. um you know
so we have China, USA, a [clears throat]
lot of other countries that are building
Europe you've just been telling me about
as well. Maybe you can just sort of give
us a quick overview of you know what is
investable at this stage and where.
>> Yeah. So look from our perspective
because we do mostly growth investing we
need to see proper ROI actual traction.
Uh we we care about what the customer is
actually saying and it's not just about
demos. So in the moment I think uh where
we spending most of our time is mostly
in anything that is uh call it like in
the world of industrial automation
vertical vertical integration for for
automation in some capacity. some of the
picks and shovels of the areas of
everything in the under layer of call it
like the infrastructure for robots in a
sense. Um I think look if you're looking
at the US probably that's where you find
like talent around AI in capital. If you
look at Europe you'll probably see a lot
of very good talent in the in the
engineering world. We actually invest in
a company called Robco based out of
Munich. Um amazing amazing engineering
workforce recently actually opened uh an
office in San Francisco as well. Uh, and
probably what you see in in in the east,
um, is some really cool demos that I'm
not sure that could actually hold up for
more than a couple of hours. Um, so I
think yeah, and in Israel because I'm
I'm actually based in Tel Aviv, uh, we
see a lot around uh, anything connects
to uh, semis, sensing, automation,
around defense. Um, so a lot of
opportunity there as well.
So when you talk about
robots, it's really a manifestation of
so many type of technologies and
anything from the brain through the
body, energy, infrastructure, software,
fleets, [clears throat]
orchestration. So it's tons of stuff.
It's way not aligned right now. are so
many gaps and some of the things we're
seeing now is a is some sort of
renaissance of a
brand marketing brain
push but it's really lagging in a big
way. Okay. So, but some of the lagging
part are really um nobody talks about.
Okay. So, we try to invest in what
nobody talks about. Okay. So the it's
definitely not the brain
the brain is mostly in the US somehow
here
but what's spread around the world
nicely is Europe and Israel for example
not in the US is all the engineering
technology deep tech the scientific part
I give an example you look for a modular
compact energy okay so high density
reliable
fit to the autonomous
So high utilization, quick charging,
long life cycle. These are the
requirements that we are looking for.
Okay. So we're looking for the
fundamentals that are going to be
mobilizing the future robots. We are by
far not there on so many levels. We can
expand a little bit later on.
um like can you give us some more
examples of companies in Israel that
you're looking at and uh type of uh you
know ecosystem investments?
Um
so let's talk a little bit about the
infrastructure.
So for example, we're looking for a
sensing capability. So I give you like
two type of sensors, maybe even three.
Okay. So one says obviously is the is
vision very clear. Everybody looking for
vision sensors. So you're looking for
sensors that has high resolution,
can withstand some weather.
So if you look at the borrow for
mobility, you have all this classical
radar versus camera versus lighter. So
we have in our portfolio a lighter
company that has a very unique
technology that can absorb light from a
you know reflection and uh very low cost
very you know uh low in maintenance as
well and it really a good fit for both
industrial automotive even defense type
of applications. opening name is
leadwave.
It's [snorts]
roundish type of stage. So it does
didn't appear on RA radar yet. But uh
that's one example. Another example is
another type of sensor sensor that sense
uh gas molecules.
So
you have a tiny uh type of sensors that
are sitting on a chip that has a certain
tunnel size into them that can fit a
certain size of molecules and you can
program the the width of this tunnel to
basically filter the right level of
molecules. Hence you can filter for type
of gas. So you can identify fire safety
issues and it's very small. It can go
anywhere. So these are type of
technologies that are sensing
technologies that we're looking at.
Company name is Vokai if you like to see
that
>> and and anything particular your end.
>> Yeah I think again because uh we do much
more late stage investing and looking
for actual traction. Um what we want to
see is is more distribution and actually
help build it in the US. Um we have a
company called Exodo actually maps the
underground without digging. very very
unique technology that has been built
over a decade basically connecting five
sensors together and doing data fusion
together with AI and basically once you
use their essentially robots you
actually get a map of the underground uh
3D map uh goes uh for mostly
infrastructure and utilities
infrastructure in uh utility
infrastructure projects today so we're
looking for much more of a distribution
a lot of what we're looking at I think
is uh obviously what Tal is investing in
just needs to see a little bit more
commercial traction action in a way uh
in defense. Look uh I think there's a
lot of lot what to do in physical AI in
the world of defense in uh in Israel or
in Tel Aviv. Um and that's a lot of what
uh we invested as well.
>> Like if we took as a percentage like B2B
versus B2C, I mean I want a robot that
can clean my laundry and everything.
This is my GBT moment, you know. Please
somebody build it out there quickly. You
know, I don't think it's quite there
yet. But like as an investor, like how
much of my uh capital should I allocate
into like B2C, B2B?
Um, look, you allocated some of it
already to figure and stuff. Um,
>> because they're going to do my laundry
at some point, but I'm sure they're
going to do a lot more industrial.
>> Um, look, I would say at at least for
our stage, it's not interesting to be
honest. Um, consumer application, I
think it's uh it has many years before
we actually get to experience the CHP
moment. I would love to have someone do
I love Robbo does my laundry as well,
but I don't think we're there and I
don't think we're close. um
>> hold you to it as well.
>> Yeah, I always say I don't like to bet,
but like my job is a little bit betting
as well. So, uh 10 years probably.
>> I think it's shorter, but uh but I agree
with Raz. I think that it's going to be
much easier to do it in a more
controlled environment. So we will
definitely see the the first wave likely
to see it in a in a more controlled
industrial commercial environment by
which you can control fleets limited
bounding authority and so on and so
forth before we let them run loose in
our neighborhoods. So definitely that
with regards to the
particular question of of of B2C B2B
it's going be going beyond that okay
what we witnessing is a is a increasing
gap between capability and as you said
deployment and it it means that
regulation is is back everybody's back
cap capability is running the reason we
are talking about this concept now is
because capability is way ahead and the
gap is widening Actually
why what it means it means that we'll be
able to commercially control it with the
B2B much earlier than we we allow it to
do this B2C before the regulator is
going to wake up.
Um like I know there's a lot of builders
in the room. So like where does
everybody raise capital? I mean like God
bless uh Jensen cuz he said physical AI
and everybody started investing you know
uh more actively and we've seen the VC
numbers going up. But like if people
want to raise capital uh come to VCs,
where are you seeing the bulk of uh the
money get deployed? Is it the US? Is it
China?
>> Look, for now I think uh unfortunately a
lot of it is still around the hype uh
around the more B2C applications. But uh
I would say there's probably starting to
see a shift. I think people are starting
to understand that the TAM for physical
AI is just enormous and much much much
bigger than software and I would say
even bigger than AI potentially. um at
the end of the day is replacing labor in
a sense and given the fact that you're
replacing labor the time is almost
unlimited. It's basically anything a
human could do. Um so I think the
industry for for physical AI is
everything. Not every single company
needs to be like a figure or even like
our portfolio that has to build
everything vertically integrated from uh
companies that tal have that do the
sensing to the software layer to then
the distribution to then the supply
chain and everything around it. I think
there's definitely layers inside that
people need um a potential company to
actually do it for them and they don't
have to go and build everything
themselves. Um so I think there's
definitely some of what we define as
like picks and shovels data sensing that
Tal is invested in uh in a lot of those
area. That's for sure.
>> So I think there's a big problem there.
I think that uh we seeing a tremendous
amount of money going to the wrong
place.
So and that's what creates the gap that
is widening between perception or
perceive and what between this and what
happened in reality. Okay. Uh there was
a recent um report I think 24th of June
came out out of London by very reputable
consulting company basically naming the
contribution of the GDP of the AI to the
GDP is like4%.
Maybe they're underplaying it, but
honestly, this is these are these are
the margins. The the hype is going to
the brain, to the mind, to the Silicon
Valley, to the competition among those,
you know, humanoids and robots that
obviously they're amazing. But we all
know it's going to commoditize. Okay,
it's it's going to be there. But what's
not going to going to commoditize is the
layer that is going to be in the
factories. the layer that was spok
speaking about the layer that translates
all this talent all this amazing
capability into reality. So this is and
this layer is is the translation of the
capability into value and we don't know
nobody's everybody's ignoring it right
now. Nobody's talking about that. No
people are doing it. Okay there's
there's one example of companies is
doing it actually. It's called Rivian.
you're familiar with driven the this
west coast new vehicle company they're
actually one example by which they
really I think they really get it they
get this layer and I give you an example
what do I mean by get it h they just
raised it's still stealth mode but they
raised hundreds of millions of dollars
uh to a company called mind.ai and what
m.ai is doing is basically
uh building a factory for robots and the
factory is [clears throat] connected
real live data from the Riven factory to
mind.ai AI factory basically building
the robots [snorts] on the go based on
what the robots and humans are doing in
reven factory thus creating what I call
habitat for those type of upcoming
robots to become ready for the real real
duty okay when they step out of the out
of the robot floor so and and and what
the big misfunding here is that you keep
funding the robots you don't keep
finding those layers basically
>> feels like the LLMs right they get the
you know hundred billion dollar funding
and actually you worry about the
business model later whereas like the
picks and shovels and the uh like hands
and everything like that. I mean one of
the big problems in uh you know robots
is hands maybe we can discuss you know
seen any companies invested in that
space.
>> Yeah. So uh we invest in a company
called roco based out of Munich and uh
now also San Francisco they do fully
vertically integrated industrial
automation basically. If you can think
about those uh those hands instead of me
taking now um a certain tool and putting
it in a box, you know, like something
that usually um very cheap labor, but uh
ideally you don't want a human to do it.
You want a human to focus on something
much more interesting. They're doing it
at 99.9%
accuracy, 27 247, no union, no one is
sick, three shifts a day. basically uh
hundreds of robots already in deployment
with major major um
that's a funny one
major deployments with some of the
largest enterprises you can think of
mostly uh today based in the US and
Europe um so I think that that is one
example but they did uh obviously had to
build all of it is fully vertically
integrated so they own the software the
hardware uh the data everything around
it including the distribution as well um
but again I don't think that everyone
needs to do exactly at
>> uh ju just uh you know remark I I 100%
agree but I think that and that goes
back to the to the this missing layer
there's an there's a concept that we
kind of gloss over sometimes and that's
where
when you have an an automated entity
like a robot it's not enough to control
just the automation there's a there's an
ecosystem by which it has to act and uh
this ecosystem has to act. It has to be
ready for this. So it has to uh measure
what the what the robot is doing. So for
example uh you know we're doing things
in mobility as well. So we invested in a
company called no traffic. Okay. Now
it's a larger company but um they just
raised the 90 million. They are doing
all this all their business right now
mostly in the US. the traffic management
system sit on top of a intersection
doing AI analysis about how to manage
traffic better. Okay,
but this is the type of infrastructure
play that allows the autonomous erh
autonomous enablement from the
environment side not from the object or
the model side. Okay, it basically
provide the feedback to this now
[snorts] chaotic robot taxi scene we're
going to have uh you know in the in the
United States and soon coming here. I
say chaotic because everybody's working
by their own standards. Okay, you don't
need to have any federal regulation to
deploy a a level four vehicle in the US.
just can put it on the road and you can
go state by state. Maybe you can be uh
you can be uh limited but there are some
state don't impose anything. So you
basically can just let those vehicle
ride and what we need more of and the
regulation will pick it up later on is
those sensing and the software that
build trust within the public to allow
those automation to act basically. So
that's another element of example of a
sub startup we uh invested in now
they're generating revenue just serving
their goal but in the back pocket they
have already the the autonomous
supervising type of facilitation. I
think maybe I'll add something. I think
that a lot of it's going to uh your
previous question. Some of what investor
are missing is that at the end of the
day there's a hardware component
involved and you can't do it without
actual distribution and having it
outside or at the customer or at the
consumer one day and without that it
doesn't mean anything. So even having
like the best technology doesn't
necessarily mean that that company will
be the winning company in that in that
space. You have to think about how do
you do your go to market? Where do you
actually deploy it? How do you do your
supply chain? How do you get to the
actual distribution? Do you use SIS? Are
you not using SI? Do you do it all
yourself? How do you actually speak to
the customer? How you get the
validation? And the more that you have
deployed in this in the field, you'll
get even more data where the data loop
is actually creating a significant mode
for you. So I think that's something
that uh maybe some of the investors are
missing.
>> Yeah. I mean this these robot companies
are going to suck up a lot of cash right
at the front end, right? So you have to
also like you know us personally we want
to invest in company a founder that can
raise cash you know he has to be on his
mission but he's also got to be
mercenary and that's where Elon is right
you know he's uh mission driven
nothing's getting in his way but he can
also raise a shitload of cash you know
um so just for exposure for people at
the moment we're like limited right I
don't know what's going on here we need
somebody send in a robot please we need
this fixed uh but um yeah like in terms
of exposure right we have funds like
yourself. Um, we have a friend of mine,
Andrew Kang. He's just launched a
listed, uh, effectively a listed ETF.
Uh, are there any other ways? You seeing
any other ways for people to get
exposure?
>> Look, I think public market is a little
bit harder for now because, uh, there's
not much there. I mean, uh, there's
obviously SpaceX that wants to do more.
Tesla wants to build the humanoid. I
think that's a bit harder. I think, uh,
at the end of the day, for now, it's
just the beginning. So, private market
uh, is the way for now. I think it's
starting from funds like TAL who are
actually funding everyone then funds
like ourselves who are actually trying
to help the go to market and the scale.
Um so I think it that will take a little
bit of time before the regular retailer
person is able to get full exposure.
There's some creative ways obviously
buying secondaries and all those
secondary platforms and all that but I'm
I think you need to have you need to
know why are you buying something like
that. So I think that that I would be uh
careful maybe
>> I mean
>> the experts
>> look the first of all you you touch a
very key point I mean on top of
everything is about the execution of the
of the growth of the company and uh
obviously you have to have capability to
raise funds in particularly deep tech
type of long endeavor that we're talking
here uh you basically have to raise
money with nothing much to show I mean I
wish Raz will manage to show this growth
all the time but it's not that uh not
that easy but uh so you you expect this
up and down particularly now because
what we're experiencing now or I assume
we're about to experiencing
so if indeed we are headed for this
bubble that everybody's kind of
whispering about or not maybe not so
much then this is going to be the
biggest mistake to run away once this
thing is going down because the real
thing is going to happen after post
bubble okay and and and and the and the
and we we kind of hinted about this both
of us and also your questions in the
previous uh few minutes the fact that we
we having so much money goes and we have
you know the the the only thing we can
show for is tokens nobody understand
what's in the end of the token really
and then there's a gap widening not much
impact to the GDP so uh which means that
probably a lot of the money that goes
out there is not going to come back.
Okay. And then so
the question is going to be slow. It's
going to be big. What's going to happen
after? But what's going to happen after?
We're going to have the infrastructure
basically. So then then we're going to
have the winners. So this why you need
to have patience and capability to raise
and capability to manage everybody
around you including investors,
including your customers or potential
customers or whatever. So we got a
couple of minutes left. We're going to
go some uh crazy predictions cuz like
look, we're so early in this space.
Maybe I'll lead with uh two things. I'm
going to yeah take your 10 year bet. I
I'm going to say we're going to like my
clothes are going to be ironed in three
to five years. You know, I'm going to uh
be bullish. The other thing that I'm
concerned about coming from North Asia,
um you know, where people, you know, I
saw that robot out there, the companion
robot, you know, I'm actually concerned
about human growth rates, you know, in
the future because I think uh you know,
somebody will order up a robot and uh
end up marrying a robot, you know. Uh so
those are my two predictions. My clothes
get ironed and people start marrying
robots in under five years.
>> I'll uh keep the hat of the conservative
growth investor here. Uh I would say
it'll take time but we're definitely
seeing a lot of value and ROI and
automation and that's why we're
investing in it. I think uh maybe in the
next uh by call it like 2030 a lot of
what uh companies will sell is
essentially labor. So you can think
about it as like labor as a service or
robot as a service. Um at the end of the
day the the same way that Tal spoke
about like tokens what is the end of the
token. Uh I think the customer at the
end of the day wants to see value and if
you're replacing human workers you'll
just basically price the labor. Um so I
think that is definitely a trend that
we'll probably see going.
>> So maybe I ask you quickly on few
dimension your question. So number one
is about us people. [snorts] Okay. So I
do think that eventually we're going to
benefit from the capabilities of the
automation once we we address this
missing layer that I was talking before
which will be able to translate this
capability to value by the way it's a
layer of trust okay we didn't talk about
it much but it's a what the robots are
doing they they're very capable but we
don't trust them we don't have mechanism
to trust them we don't have the system
to trust them once we'll be able to
trust them they'll be able to iron your
clothes and do many more other things.
Then on the on the human side, we will
have to decide.
We have to decide what are we going to
do in our life and what are we not going
to do. Okay, you know already that
you're not going to iron your clothes.
Okay. But some people will, you know, um
if we don't use capabilities, we're
going to lose it. So what what do we
choose to lose? That's a deeper
question. Yes. And what what are we want
the machine to do once we trust it? So
these are the questions that we have
about 10 years to understand a little
bit how to answer.
>> It's an exciting space. I think
everybody should be involved. I've got
three young sons, three sons and I was
just I'm just like go all in on this
physical AI. So I wish everybody the
best and thank you for your time today.
>> Thank you.